-The committee investigating
the attempted coup
on January 6th
has proven,
in painstaking detail,
that Donald Trump orchestrated
a premeditated plan
for overthrowing the government
on January 6th,
even though his closest aides
and advisors knew
his stolen election claims
were insane.
In fact, it was all
such an obvious scam
that Trump campaign official
Kimberly Guilfoyle,
the fiancée of Donald Trump Jr.,
got paid an obscene amount
of money
for a speech that lasted less
than three minutes.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
The political world
is still processing
the aftermath of some
of the revelations
from the January 6th Committee's
second hearing on Monday.
For example, Rudy Giuliani,
wants you all to know
he is very upset
at the accusation leveled
by former Trump aides,
in sworn testimony,
that he was wasted
on election night.
-Former Trump lawyer
Rudy Giuliani has now responded
to those accusations in the
January 6th Committee hearings
that he was drunk
on election night,
Giuliani writing in part...
-Oh, sorry, buddy,
you just gave yourself away.
No one's favorite drink is
Diet Pepsi.
[ Laughter ]
Is your favorite cookie
Lorna Doone's?
[ Laughter ]
Diet Pepsi is what you drink
on a flight
when they don't have Diet Coke
or lemonade or chocolate milk
or coconut water or camel spit
or regular Pepsi.
[ Laughter ]
If a waiter ever says,
"We don't have Diet Coke.
Is Diet Pepsi okay?",
you're legally allowed
to stab them with a fork.
[ Laughter ]
Maybe Rudy has an unpopular
favorite drink on purpose,
you know, so he has a cover
story when he's at a bar.
[ As Giuliani ]
I'll take a Diet Pepsi.
"Oh, we don't have that, sir."
[ As Giuliani ] That's too bad.
In that case, I'll have, uh,
16 ounces of scotch
in a watering can.
[ Laughter ]
Also, what do you mean,
you refused
all alcohol that evening?
Like people were trying
to get you to drink,
[ Laughter ]
but you said no.
Feels like you're being
a little too defensive.
You sound like me coming home
at 2:00 am in high school.
[ Posh accent ]
No, Mom, I'm sober as a judge!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, they tried
to get me to drink,
but I said nay, I will not
[ Laughter ]
sully the good Meyers name
with the demon taste
of Jagermeister.
Oh, no, no.
I'm going to barf.
Move, Mom.
Move.
[ Laughter ]
I doubt anyone was trying
to get Rudy drunk,
although, I could definitely see
Trump aides, on election night,
trying to overserve him,
just so he passes out.
"We're all upset about Arizona,
Mr. Mayor.
You know what?
Why don't you drink this
and then go lie down
on the lawn outside?"
[ Laughter ]
Because, according to the sworn
testimony obtained
by the committee,
Rudy was just wandering
around the White House
on election night,
looking for the president,
so we could tell him
to declare the election stolen.
-Do you remember
Rudy Giuliani being
at the White House
on election night
and into the early hours
the next morning?
-I do.
What do you remember
about when he came?
-Um...
[ Clears throat ]
He...
He was, um...
[ Laughter ]
They were -- I had heard
that he was, uh,
upstairs, you know,
in that aforementioned
reception area,
and...um,
he was looking
to talk to the president.
-You know, you like to think
of the White House
as a stately, dignified place,
full of decorum and history,
and then you learn,
via congressional testimony,
that a drunken potato goblin
was upstairs,
[ Laughter ]
just wandering around all night,
banging on doors,
looking, not just for anyone,
but the president,
and, by the way, got to him.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Giuliani ]
Excuse me, sir.
Do you happen to know
where Donald is?
I need to talk to him.
"Mr. Mayor, that's just a bust
of Abraham Lincoln."
[ Laughter ]
[ As Giuliani ]
He's a bust, all right.
He won't even give me
my Diet Pepsi.
[ Laughter ]
And, by the way,
it's worth underscoring
this point --
it's not Democrats saying
Rudy was drunk
at the White House
on election night.
It's his fellow
Trump supporters,
like former Trump campaign
spokesman Jason Miller.
-Was there anyone in that
conversation who,
in your observation,
had had too much to drink?
[ Laughter ]
-Tell me more about that.
What was your observation
about his, uh,
potential intoxication
during that -- that discussion
about what the president
should say
when he addressed the nation
on election night.
-I mean, I think we can guess
at his level of intoxication.
I mean, look at him.
[ Laughter ]
For a guy Rudy Giuliani's age,
there's very little room
between stone-cold sober
and sloshed out of his
[bleep] mind.
[ Laughter ]
It's a little like
when your grandma
has one glass of wine
with an ice cube in it
when you're out to dinner
and she starts telling you
what an [bleep] your father
was as a baby.
[ Laughter ]
So, Rudy may have been drunk
on election night,
according to former
Trump advisors,
but his suggestion
that Trump just declare
the election stolen
was not some random,
drunken impulse.
As the committee documented,
Trump had been openly declaring,
for months
in advance of the election,
that the only way he could lose
was if it was stolen from him.
He was just desperately
searching for any pretext,
any justification at all,
that he could use
to make that declaration
and Rudy,
along with a gang of other
crazy weirdos, gave it to him.
In fact, Trump officials
kept telling him,
over and over and over again,
that each individual claim
of election fraud was nonsense
and, rather than push back
and offer his own evidence
for each claim,
Trump would just move on
to some other insane claim.
that much of the information
he's getting is false...
-I told him that the stuff
that his people were shoveling
out to the public was bullshit.
I mean, that the claims
of fraud were bullshit.
-Quick tangent -- when Bill Barr
says bull[bleep] in the clip,
we don't have to bleep it,
but when I repeat him, we do.
[ Laughter ]
That's where we're at,
as a nation.
I'm not allowed to say a word,
on my show,
but Donald Trump's
former attorney general is.
That's some bull[bleep].
[ Laughter and applause ]
But that testimony
is also revealing.
Trump kept pitching insane ideas
and then,
when they were challenged,
instead of trying to provide
evidence for those claims,
he just moved on
to the next one.
He was like a kid trying
to explain to his teacher
why he didn't do his homework.
"Uh, dog ate it."
You don't have a dog.
"It was someone else's dog.
It broke into my house.
It ate my homework.
And yet, instead of tracking
down this criminal canine,
you're grilling me
about my "Tale of Two Cities"
book report? That's some...
-Bull[bleep].
[ Laughter ]
-Interesting --
we had to beep it that time
because it wasn't us
repeating the news.
It was us using him
to make a punchline of a joke.
[ Laughter ]
So, when we use it as a joke,
we have to beep it,
but when it's newsworthy,
we're allowed to do it
the way it was said.
And I think explaining it
the way I'm doing it
is newsworthy.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Which I think is [bleep] cool?
Let's find out.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Let's watch tonight.
I think I was making news.
Ooh! I know what --
If Bill Barr gets a talk show,
he can show what I just did.
[ Laughter ]
Again, that testimony,
in particular, is so important
because it establishes that
Trump knew what he was doing.
He had criminal intent.
It was a plan, not a whim.
He and his cronies want you
to think January 6th
was just some random,
one-off event
that was neither preplanned
nor part of a broader attempt
to overthrow the government.
For example,
Rudy has a podcast --
because I guess
that's what they give you now,
instead of meds -- where
[ Laughter ]
he reacted to the first
committee hearing
by claiming the FBI
had found no evidence
of preplanning
for the January 6th attack.
-They have become,
not just an embarrassment.
They've become a danger
to the freedom of Americans.
The FBI, in its investigation,
found no such structure.
They found that --
pretty shortly after,
they found that there was
no evidence of preplanning
of this event.
So, then you'd have to say
it was some kind
of a spontaneous --
And I think, by this time,
we're all quite convinced, now,
that it's not a -- uh,
it's not an insurrection.
It's a -- It's a riot.
And -- And -- And one that,
according to the FBI,
on several occasions,
was not preplanned.
-Alright, first of all,
the Justice Department
has already charged
multiple members
of militias
and other right-wing groups
with seditious conspiracy,
so that's wrong.
Second, how the [bleep]
does Rudy
have more than one camera
set up? I mean...
[ Laughter ]
[ Fresh laughter and applause ]
...I did --
You guys, I did an actual
network television show
by myself, in my house,
for a year.
All I had was an iPad
and a ring light.
And then everyone in the YouTube
comment section
was saying mean things
to me, like,
"Is this show hosted
by Tintin's ghost?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
I would've killed
for a second camera
or a cool leather chair
like that.
[ Laughter ]
Rudy's supposed to be
the drunk, crazy person trying
to overthrow the government.
Meanwhile, he's got
a multicam setup in his office,
with a desk and a leather chair
and I was the one with my hair
down to my shoulders,
talking to a [bleep] painting
of a Sea Captain.
[ Laughter and applause ]
By the way, if you're wondering
where the Sea Captain went,
he ran into a little
legal trouble.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I told him to get off 4chan,
but he wouldn't listen!
[ Laughter ]
Also, I want to go back to this.
-They have become,
not just an embarrassment.
They've become a danger
to the freedom of Americans.
-You really want to call
anyone else an embarrassment?
Is that really the word
you want to use?
[ Laughter ]
There was an entire
nationally televised
congressional hearing,
this week,
about you being a sloppy drunk.
[ Laughter ]
You used to be
on magazine covers,
as America's Mayor,
and now, you're most famous
for screaming
outside a landscaping company,
like a guy who was trying
to return a used bag of mulch.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Giuliani ]
So what if I already put it?
Yeah, yeah, what if I already
put the mulch down and I
decided I don't want any more,
so I scooped it all back up
and I put it back in the bag?
And no, you cannot
hold me responsible
if there's a dog turd in there.
[ Laughter ]
If you should blame anyone,
it's the dog who broke
into my house!
[ Laughter ]
So, they knew the allegations
of fraud were all insane.
It was a scam.
And there's really
no better proof
of the fact that it was a scam
than this detail, revealed
by one of the members
of the committee.
Trump campaign official
Kimberly Guilfoyle,
who is also
Donald Trump Jr.'s fiancée,
was paid an absolutely grotesque
amount of money
for her speech
on the day of the insurrection,
a speech that lasted less
than three minutes.
-The committee
has found information
that Kimberly Guilfoyle
was paid $60,000
to speak at the rally
on January 6th,
$60,000 for a speech that was,
what, three minutes?
-If that.
-If that. Three minutes long.
And what have you heard,
over the last several hours,
since that revelation,
about how people
in Trumpworld feel about this?
-So, I want to say two things
about that.
People in Trumpworld
are sharing that clip.
They are aghast that this is
the amount of money
that she got for a speech
to introduce her boyfriend.
-$60,000 for a speech that was
less than three minutes long,
and to introduce her fiancée.
If there was ever a man
who needed no introduction,
[ Laughter ]
it's Don Jr. at a far-right
conservative rally.
That's like going up
at a "Star Trek" convention
to introduce William Shatner.
Uh, they know him.
[ Laughter ]
[ Transatlantic accent ]
Many years ago, a starship
set out on a five-year mission.
"Move, or we'll kill you!"
[ Laughter ]
By the way,
now, I guess we know
what she really meant
when she said this at the RNC
in 2020 --
-The best is yet
to come!
-$5,200.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Also, if she genuinely thought
this was a revolution
to save America from tyranny,
then why was she getting paid
at all?
It's not a corporate
speaking gig
where you charge
your standard rate.
You think Paul Revere got paid
for his midnight ride?
[ Laughter ]
[ New York accent ]
"I need to bring the lights.
I got to remember my lines.
You're making me
use my own horse."
Who can forget his famous quote?
[ Laughter and cheering ]
The committee has proven,
in exhaustive detail,
not just that Trump's
stolen election claims were BS,
but he knew they were BS
and virtually
everyone around him told him
they were BS.
They were both a scam
to raise money
and a fabricated pretext
for an attempted coup,
a coup orchestrated, in part,
by Rudy Giuliani,
whose blood alcohol level
on election night was roughly...
-60,000.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.